Genau gesagt, Chaos Radio bei Fritz der Computer Club. Und jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat und so auch heute, auch wenn die Jungs von Chaos Computer Club leider noch nicht da sind, aber das wird sich bestimmt klären, denn heute ist zweijähriges Jubiläum, genauer gesagt die 23. Sendung Chaos Radio.
Das sind sie.
Heil Dir Eris, unsere Göttin, Hüterin des Chaos, des Diskords und der Konfusion. Wir sind ein Stamm von Philosophen, Theologen, Magiern, Wissenschaftlern, Künstlern, Clowns und ähnlichen Wahnsinnigen und sind beseelt von dir und deinen Taten. Du bist das Chaos. Du bist der Stoff, aus dem wir unsere Rhythmen gewinnen. Du bist der Geist, der unsere Kinder und Clowns in freudiger Anarchie lachen lässt. Man muß noch Chaos in sich haben, um einen tanzenden Stern zu gebären und wir werden den Fluch des Graugesichts von uns schütteln und das Kreative über das Zerstörerische siegen lassen. Und niemals werden wir glauben, was wir lesen. Lasst sie nicht das Eschaton immanentisieren, Heil Eris, Alles Heil Diskordia, Kallisti.
Ich hab schon gesagt, 23.
Ausgabe vom Chaosradio und ich bin eine Menge Chaos gewohnt hier in dieser Sendung. Johnny, Ihr Mikrofon übrigens, schönen guten Abend. In dieser Computer Blue Moon Ausgabe, die jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz hier stattfindet. Eigentlich zusammen mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute hab ich ein kleines Problem, dieses Tape zum Beispiel wurde mir gerade zugespielt, unbedingt wichtig für die Sendung. Don Stone aka Green Man mixt da drauf und das klingt erstmal gut. Ist ungewöhnlich hier einfach ein Tape laufen zu lassen in dieser Sendung und auch alles anderes ungewöhnlich, denn der Chaos Computer Club ist nicht aufgetaucht, stattdessen sitzen vier mir unbekannte junge Männer vor mir, die sich gerade hier eingefunden haben, die sich vorgestellt haben als Legion des dynamischen Discords und die ich alle noch nicht kenne, wer seid ihr?
Tordfriester des Ordens.
Mein Name ist Theodor Prinz, der tapferen Hüter der Flamme des Herbsts.
Ich bin J. Random Hacker, Wächter des Amulets von Yendur.
Und dann ist hier noch Zapf Dingbaz, der Allwissende.
Das klingt alles erstmal interessant. Ihr wisst schon, dass die drei Stunden Sendung vor euch stehen, dass wir hier Radio machen. Könnt ihr dazu was beitragen?
Ja, wir wollen das sehr ernst nehmen. Und deswegen möchten wir auch gleich von vorne anfangen, damit auch die Grundlagen klar sind von der Entstehung unseres Universums. Das war nämlich so.
Die Erschaffung der Welt. Im Anfang schuf Gott Himmel und der Erde. Die Erde aber war wüst und wirr. Finsternis lag über der Urflut und Gottes Geist schwebte über dem Wasser. Gott sprach, es werde Licht und es wurde Licht. Gott sah, da das Licht gut war. Gott schied das Licht von der Finsternis und Gott nannte das Licht Tag und die Finsternis nannte er Nacht. Und es wurde Abend und es wurde Morgen, erster Tag. Dann sprach Gott, ein Gewölbe entstehe mitten im Wasser und scheide Wasser von Wasser. Gott machte also das Gewölbe und schied das Wasser unterhalb des Gewölbes vom Wasser oberhalb des Gewölbes. So gestarr es und Gott nannte das Gewölbe Himmel. Es wurde Abend und es wurde Morgen, zweiter Tag. Dann sprach Gott, das Wasser unterhalb des Himmels sammle sich an einem Ort, damit das Trockene sichtbar werde.
So, ich versuche hier mal ein bisschen Ordnung ins Chaos zu kriegen. Das wird eine andere Sendung, soviel steht fest. Im Internetchat, der hier natürlich wieder offen ist, in dieser Sendung fragt halt jemand, was das heutige Thema ist und Fake antwortet Bob Geldorf, hat Michael Hutchens auf dem Gewissen, dass ist das Thema. Eigentlich war das Thema 23. Ausgabe vom Chaos Radio und wie gesagt die Legion des Dynamischen Discords ist hier im Studio. Ihr wisst aber schon, dass es bei dieser Radiosendung unter anderem auch im weitesten Sinn am Computer gehen soll.
Heil Eris, weil die Sache war ja die griechische Göttin Eris, die Göttin des Zwidraks, der Auseinandersetzungen des Streits, hatte eine ganz gute Idee. Sie besorgte sich einen großen Bobble haschisch, Acapulco Gold und schrieb drauf Kallisti. Kallisti heißt für die Allerschönste. Da die Götter gerade eine Versammlung hatten, rollte sie diesen Haschisch Bobble also inmitten der Versammlung der Götter und es begann ein gar fürchterlicher Streit, wäre nun der Allerschönste. Die Allerschönste für Mia sei.
In Wirklichkeit wollten sie bloß mal einen rauchen?
Nein, nein. Das war eine sehr ernste Diskussion, wer dann jetzt die Schönste war. Weil unter den Göttern gibt es da schon so gewisse Kämpfe. Und das Problem war aber, womit sie nicht gerechnet hatten, das ist bei Göttern nun mal so, da wurde eine Unmenge von Energie frei in diesem Streit. Und diese Energie entzündete diesen großen Bobble Haschisch und machte die Götter gar fürchterlich bekifft. So entstand das Universum und der große Narf fragte dann, ist ihres wahr?
Alles ist wahr.
Auch Dinge, die falsch sind?
Auch falsche Dinge sind wahr.
Wie kann dem so sein?
Man, ich weiß es nicht, ich hab's nicht gemacht.
Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da so in der Sendung habt. Nachdem der Applaus sich gelegt hatte, fragte eine Frau namens Kajetschi, ob es nicht respektlos sei, sich in die Angelegenheit unseres Vaters der Sonne einzumischen. Engel Rielt erwiderte, dass der Mensch Teil der Natur sei und was er tut, als natürlich und nicht als Einmischung aufgefasst werden sollte. Da unterbricht Gua Artin voller Zorgen und weist darauf hin, dass er selbst, eine wenig attraktive Mutation, das Ergebnis eines Sich-Einmischens in die Natur darstellt. Er wirft Engel Rielt vor, dass die Atlantan nicht in der Lage seien, die wahre Natur zu begreifen, noch die Gesetze, von der sie geleitet wird. Er sagt, dass Menschen Gesetzen unterliegen, so auch alle Dinge und Vorgänge in der Natur. Dass der Unterschied zwischen dem Menschen und der Natur darin liegt, dass der Mensch die Natur Gesetze, die ihn leiten, missachten kann. Wort fährt fort, mit der Menschheit können wir so sprechen, wie wir über unsere eigenen Maschinen sprechen, nämlich von erwarteter Leistung oder Füllterleistung. Erfüllt eine Maschine nicht das, was wir erwarten, versuchen wir sie zu reparieren. Wir wollen, dass sie tut, was sie tun sollte, was sie tun kann. Ich denke, wir haben das Recht und die Pflicht, dasselbe vom Menschen zu verlangen, dass er das leisten sollte, was er leisten kann. Ein gealteter und belustigt reinschauender Wissenschaftler namens Luv Girapt unterbricht ihn, aber Menschen sind keine Maschinenquad. Ganz genau antwortet Quad. Das habe ich längst in Betracht gezogen. Deshalb habe ich neue Wörter geschaffen. Wörter, die strenger sind als sollen und können. Wenn ein Mensch das leistet, was er soll und kann, dann nenne ich das das Gute. Und jede geringere Leistung nenne ich das Böse. Die fremdländische Idee wird mit allgemeinem Gelächter begrüßt.
Das ist ein Schicksal, das nicht ein Schicksal ist. Chaos Radio, eigentlich der Computer Blumen bei Fritz jeden Mittellmonat, heute eher mit Betonung auf dem ersten Wort des Titels, nämlich auf dem Chaos vor mir, vier abgesandte der Legion des dynamischen Discords und wenn ich am Anfang gedacht hab, es handelt sich um eine Pseudorelegion, bin ich jetzt der Überzeugung, dass zumindest ein gewisser Wahrheitsgehalt vielleicht erkennbar sein kann und vielleicht kriegen wir auch einen anderen Zugang zu den Jungs. Da der Chaos Computer Club immer noch nicht hier ist, kennt ihr die überhaupt? Habt ihr einen Bezug zu denen?
Nie sah ich eine rote Kuh, nie hoffe ich eine zu sehen, aber ich sage euch in aller Ruhe, lieber keine sein und eine sehen.
Ja, vielleicht könnt ihr nach dem Fritz-Kurz-Info-Ihr ein bisschen mehr Licht in die Dunkelheit bringen. Wir werden natürlich irgendwann hier auch wieder die Telefone öffnen.
Und wenn ihr hübsch brav seid, erklären wir euch sogar die Sache mit dem Fröschen.
Bis jetzt ging es ja doch eher um die Erschaffung von allem. Was haben Forscher damit zu tun, bitte?
Also das war so...
Die IC-Karte hat verschiedene Daten auf ihrem Streifen, also Banknachzahl, Kontonummer, Kartenfolge, das ist auch das, was drauf steht, aber auch die sogenannten Offsets. Die Offsets waren sozusagen ursprünglich dafür da, um mit diesem General-Schlüssel, der in allen Geldautomaten drin war, den Pool-Schlüssel, also auch auf denselben Pin zu kommen, den auch der Institutsschlüssel bildet. Normalerweise wird die Kartennummer, also Kontonummer, Bankkartzahlkartenfolgenummer, geht in den DS-Algorithmus, wird mit dem Pool-Schlüssel verschlüsselt und da kommt dann ein Wert raus, dem dieser Offset drauf gerechnet werden muss. Oder andersrum ausgesprochen, also wenn man den Institutsschlüssel als Schlüssel verwandt, kommt direkt der Pin-Code raus. Und damit ein Kunde auch an einen Geldinstitut eines fremden Instituts gehen kann, um da Geld abzuheben, gibt es eben diesen Offset, der dem Poolschlüsselergebnis drauf verhindert wird, damit es letztendlich derselbe Pin ist. Von diesem Offset gibt es aber drei, weil die sich überlegt haben, wenn der Poolschlüssel mal rauskommt, dann muß man noch irgendwie ein paar Inreserven haben.
So, und jetzt ist die ganze Geschichte so, dass die Banden, die sich das nicht besonders gut überlegt haben, haben halt gedacht, sie bauen der DES ein und dann ist das schon sicher. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass jede einzelne Stelle der Pin aus dem Ergebnis der DES-Verschlüsselung errechnet wird und das Ergebnis der DES-Verschlüsselung sind 4 Bit, also eine Hexzahl, also Zahlen zwischen 0 und 15 und die Stellen der Pin liegen aber zwischen 0 und 10. So wird modulo 10 gerechnet auf vier einzelnen Stellen und da kommt halt das Ergebnis von 0 bis 5 doppelt so häufig raus wie das Ergebnis von 6 bis 9. Und das betrifft nicht nur den Pin selber, sondern wenn man von dem Pin den Offset abzieht, der auf den Magnetstreifen ja drauf steht, dann bekommt man wieder ein Ergebnis, das doppelt so häufig zwischen 0 und 5 liegt wie zwischen 6 und 9. Und insgesamt kann man damit die Wahrscheinlichkeit für das Erraten der Pin stark erhöhen. Das heißt, wenn man eine Karte in den Geldautomaten steckt, muss man, und drei Pins eingibt, hat man nicht eine Chance von ungefähr einem Dreitausendstel, sondern eine Chance von einem Hundertfünfzigstel, dabei die richtige Pin zu erwischen. Also fast mehr als zehnmal so hoch.
Oder um es anders zu formulieren, wir setzen kein Kartrauen in Jungfrau oder Taube. Unsere Methode ist Wissenschaft. Unser Ziel ist Religion.
Schön, dass man nach frischen Fragten Informationen über EC-Karten bekommt. Im Chat schreibt dir gerade Chaos Doppelpunkt, nur selten personifiziert gedacht, bedeutet in der Dichtung die gähnende Leere, die aus der Erde, Gaia, der Tartarus, das Dunkel entklemmern Erebos und die Nacht Müx entsprangen. Da Chaos Radio eine interative Sendung ist, da wird auch immer wieder aus dem Chat zitiert, Civi, wer auch immer das ist, meint er habe einen Flirt gesehen.
Epimenides, der Kreter, behauptete, alle Kreter lügen. Was hat man davon zu halten? Wenn Epimenides die Wahrheit spricht, so lügt er tatsächlich. Wenn er aber lügt, dann hat er mit seiner Aussage Recht. Kurzum, wir bleiben in einer seltsamen Schleife hängen.
Crush schreibt im Chat Chaos aus dem griechischen. In der antiken Vorstellung der mit ungeformten und unbegrenzten urstoffgefüllte Raum als Vorstufe des endlichen und wohlgeordneten Kosmos. Im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch sind Verwand durcheinander, totale Verwirrung, Auflösung jeder Ordnung. Und wir jetzt wieder aus dem Mexikon der antiken Mythen, Mythen und Gestalten. Einige halten auch die Diebe in Klammern Eros für ein Kind, das Chaos, wenn sie auch gewöhnlich als Sohn der Aphrodite erscheint. Das heißt zwar Chaosradio, aber das hier passiert trotzdem.
Der Präsident des Hauptverbandes der deutschen Bauindustrie, Walter, geht davon aus, dass die Branche in diesem Jahr 100.000 Arbeitsplätze einbüßt. Des Weiteren gehen nach seinen Worten 4.800 Baubetriebe pleite. Protest. In Berlin haben heute tausende Studenten für bessere Bedingungen an den Hochschulen demonstriert. Bundesweit werden mittlerweile mehr als 40 Universitäten bestreikt. Morgen ist eine Großdemonstration in Bonn geplant. Zustimmung. Das Land Brandenburg will sich an dem Notprogramm von Bund und Ländern zur Modernisierung der Hochschulbibliotheken beteiligen. Ein Sprecher des Wissenschaftsministeriums sagte, 80 Millionen Mark seien aber nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein. Beschluss. Die Abgeordneten des Bundestages haben heute mehrheitlich für den Kauf des Jagdflugzeuges Eurofighter gestimmt. Die Bundeswehr will 180 Maschinen für 23 Milliarden Mark anschaffen. Konsequenz. Die Europäische Union will die Autoindustrie notfalls per Gesetz zwingen, den Benzinverbrauch bei Neuwagen zu begrenzen. Laut Umweltkommissarin Bjergard soll kein neues Auto mehr als 5 Liter auf 100 Kilometern verbrauchen. Nachts vereinzelt sprühigen minus 4 Grad morgen bewirkt um 2 Grad Nord. Berlin-Reinickendorf A111 im Turmel-Beislag-Siedlung Richtung Oranienburg ist der rechte Streifen wegen Wartungsarbeiten bis 5 Uhr früh gesperrt. Nord Königs Wusterhausen. Der Bahnübergang Fichterstraße bleibt für den Verkehr bis 3 Uhr geschlossen. Bitte nutzt den Bahnübergang in Zesen-Rothornstraße.
Das war Martin Böttcher mit dem Fritz Kurz-Info.
FMC Lite, live in Berlin. Montag, 15. Dezember im SO36.
Hier geht's weiter mit dem Chaos Radio, leider ohne Chaos Computer Club, dafür mit der Legion des Dynamischen Discords. 23. Ausgabe des Chaos Radios, der Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Im Chat nennt sich jemand Warnduscher und der sagt, ich sollte die Legion mal nach Mithag fragen. Also die Frage soll genauer gesagt an J-Random Hacker gehen. Zum Thema NetHack. Gibt es da was zu sagen?
Ja, das Amulett von Jender ist selbstverständlich bloß eine Metapher für die seltsame Schleife. Epimenides, der Kreter, hat ja den schönen Satz geprägt, alle Kreter lügen und hat damit den ersten Widerspruch eines logischen Systems geschaffen und mit diesem Widerspruch haben sich im Laufe der Zeit viele Leute beschäftigt. Zuletzt gab es eine Arbeit, die nannte sich Prinzipia Mathematica, die relativ ausführlich darauf einging und einfach definierte, dass man in einem Aussagesystem keine Aussagen über das System selber machen kann. Also wenn ich ein mathematisches System habe und über dieses mathematische System eine Aussage machen möchte, dann brauche ich dafür eine Metasprache. Wenn ich darüber etwas sagen will, brauche ich eine Metametasprache und so weiter und so fort. Das klingt zwar wie eine tolle Idee, hat aber leider ein Problem, man kann damit so gut wie gar nichts aussagen. Also zum Beispiel der folgende Satz ist falsch, der vorangegangene Satz ist wahr. Da hat man das Problem, dass die beiden Sätze sich ja aufeinander beziehen und nicht das eine in der Metasprache sein kann, das andere nicht. Und das hat die ganzen Mathematiker ganz schön frustriert und ein gewisser Gödel ist dann auf den Trick gekommen, hat sich das angeguckt und hat die Gödelisierung erfunden. Darunter verbirgt sich, dass man sämtliche Aussagen eines Aktionensystems auch wieder mit diesem Aktionensystem abbilden kann, indem man sie einfach durchnummeriert. Und er ist dann darauf gekommen, zu jeder omega widerspruchsfreien rekursiven Klasse K von Formeln gibt es rekursive Klassenzeichen R, sodass weder V-Gen-R noch NEC-V-Gen-R zu FLG von K gehört, wobei V die freie Variable aus R ist. Oder einfacher gesagt, alle widerspruchsfreien axiomatischen Formulierungen der Zahlentheorie enthalten unentscheidbare Aussagen. Oder noch einfacher gesagt, jedes mathematische System enthält Aussagen, die nicht beweisbar sind. Oder noch einfacher gesagt, nichts ist wahr, alles ist erlaubt.
Oder um es kürzer zu formulieren.
Hör zu, das Chaos, das du unter LSD erfährst, ist keine Illusion. Die ordentliche Welt, die du dir einbildest, zu erfahren unter der künstlichen und giftigen Kost, die die Illuminaten den zivilisierten Nationen aufzwangen, ist die wahre Illusion.
Die 23. Ausgabe vom Chaos Radio. Die Musik kommt von einem Mixtape von Don Stone, also known as Green Man. Im Studio anstelle des Chaos Computer Clubs heute die Legion des dynamischen Discords, die schon einige Weisheiten und Unweisheiten hier von sich gegeben hat. Ich versuche ein bisschen zu hinterfragen, soweit es mir möglich ist. Ihr könnt helfen unter Nr. 03312 Potsdam 7481 110.
Tja, die Sache mit dem Gut und dem Bösen. Wie wir alle wissen, hat Gott am Anfang den Adam geschaffen und damit er keine Langeweile bekam, aus einer Rippe die Efe. Und die waren im Paradies und in diesem Paradies waren viele Bäume und Früchte. Und da waren halt auch der Baum des Lebens und der Baum der Erkenntnis von Gut und Böse. Und dann gab es da diese Schlange, die nicht umhin konnte, die Eva zu verführen, den Apfel vom Baum der Erkenntnis über Gut und Böse zu essen, sodass Adam und Eva letzten Endes wurden wie Gott, jedenfalls fast wie Gott. Sie wussten halt, was gut ist und was böse. Und Gott hat sie eigentlich nur aus dem Paradies geschmissen, damit sie nicht auch noch vom Baum des Lebens essen und dann noch womöglich ewig leben.
So, erste Frage an die Legion des dynamischen Discords kommt von Christian, Herr Christian.
Ja hallo, und zwar würde mich mal interessieren, was ihr genau für so eine Gruppe seid. Also dein Name ist mir unbekannt und ich weiß nicht, ich kann damit nichts anfangen.
Tja, du redest halt mit dem Illuminati-Primi.
Ja schön und was sagt man das jetzt?
Na wir vier sind die fünf, die die Welt regieren.
Ja was macht ihr denn so?
Ich werde ja nicht den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Kommentare von euch geben.
Hey, weiter gehen ist echt ein anstrengender Job.
Nun ich will versuchen dir mit einem Gleichnis zu antworten. Ein junger Mann ging zum Ravi und sagte, ich habe meinen Glauben verloren. So sagte der Ravi, und wie hast du deinen Glauben verloren? Ich habe auf der Universität Logik studiert, sagte der junge Mann. Und ich fand heraus, dass man beide Seiten eines Falles beweisen kann, wenn man klug genug ist. In der Tat, sagte der Ravi, kannst du beweisen, dass du keine Nase hast? Gewiss, sagte der Schüler, angefangen bei, aber in diesem Moment schug ihm der Ravi eins auf die Nase. Was tut deinem weh? fragte der Ravi besonst.
So Fragen gibt es aber genug an die Legion des dynamischen Diskords, die anstelle des Chaos Computer Clubs heute hier im Studio sind beim Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Simon, Entschuldige. Ja. Hast du eine Frage oder eher eine Feststellung oder irgendwas?
Ich hab eine Frage und dann noch ein Zitat zu. Also die bezeichnen sich ja als Illuminaten, die die Welt regieren. Welcher Loge gehören die dir an?
Den Freimaurern?
Kronorien oder Pneibrit oder Sparta 13?
Ach was, wir sind doch nicht so festgelegt.
Das sind doch nur Frontorganisationen, die dazu dienen, die Menschen zu versorgen.
Also unterscheidt ihr direkt Lucifer?
Also hör mal zu, ja, also ein Mensch ohne Gott ist wie ein Fisch ohne Fahrrad, um das mal klar zu sagen. Und insofern also so Kategorien wie gute, böse, Gott, Teufel, Lucifer, die sind alles uninteressante Metaphern in diesem Spiel.
Aber ihr habt ja gerade viel von Gott geredet.
Ach, von Gott.
Also ich meine, benutzt ihr doch selber.
Na ja, Gott ist halt eine gute Metapher.
Für was?
Eris, für die Göttin Eris, die wir eigentlich verirren.
Kennst du die Göttin Eris, Simon?
Direkt.
Ich auch nicht.
Also persönlich habe ich sie noch nie getroffen.
Ich habe es ja schon angedeutet, Eris ist die Göttin der Zwietracht, des Streits, der Auseinandersetzungen. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein etwas sinnvolleres Modell ist, was wir auf diesem Planeten brauchen.
Insofern wollt ihr euch streiten, das ist doch gut.
Wir wollen uns überhaupt nicht streiten, lasst das mal klar gesagt, ist ja.
Da finden wir bestimmt Hörer, die das machen.
Ja, aber das gibt doch die Antithese, die Synthese, und daraus wird doch die Synthese. Also Streit.
Nein, daraus bleiben die Widersprüche. Und die Christen, die aufgelöst. Mit der Synthese ist so ein bürgerliches Motel, um die Leute zu beruhigen.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass wir nicht mehr sehr viel Zeit haben. Wenn ich Dir einen Rat geben darf, dann gehst Du jetzt sofort aus der Wohnung und begibst Dich in die nächste Dir angenehme Kneipe, am besten dort, wo Du sofort zum Wirt durchgelassen wirst. Dann bestellst Du eine Packung Haselnüsse, noch besser Erdnüsse, noch besser zwei Packungen Erdnüsse und dann viel, viel, viel Bier.
Und was hab ich damit gekonnt?
Damit bereitest Du Dich auf die Transformation in den Hyperraum vor, denn in wenigen Minuten wird die Erde zerstört werden, um einer Hyperraumumgehungsstraße Platz zu machen.
Ich bin mir nur eingefallen, sprecht mich nicht drauf an. Ich blick auch nicht mehr durch als ihr. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Auch diese Probleme bleiben bestehen. Ist da jemand dran?
Ja, hier ist Thomas Grüßig und wo er gerade so über Kneipen und Fahrräder redet und was das riecht und über Fische, hab ich gesagt, so ist das eine ganz logische Sache. Wenn ich da mal ganz kurz eine Geschichte erzählen und zwar geht's um den Mann, der in die Kneipe f**kt und sieht da so ein Aquarium und dann kommt er mit dem Wirt ins Gespräch und dann sagt der Wirt so, Mensch, was machst du denn beruflich? Naja, er sagt da, ich studiere Logik und wie geht das? Na ganz einfach, guck mal, du hast da ein Aquarium und da sind Fische drin, also magst du doch Tiere.
Ja, ist doch logisch.
Ja, wenn du Tiere magst, dann magst du auch Menschen.
Ja, und wenn du Menschen magst, dann magst du sicherlich auch Frauen. Ja, sagt er, das ist doch logisch. Ja, wenn du Frauen magst, dann magst du ja auch Sex und alles drum herum.
Ja, ist doch logisch.
Na gut, er hat es kapiert, der driften Kumpel. Da sagt er, du weißt, ich habe jemanden getroffen, der studiert Logik. Da sagt er, hast du ein Aquarium?
Tja, die Wahrheit muß doch mal gesagt werden.
Ja, aber ich kann aufhangen jetzt.
Ich bin Gott und das stimmt.
Tja, sicher. Hast Du denn Gott?
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Du bist hiermit zum Mapst anhand, nein Päpstin heißt es glaube ich.
Päpstin Anja. Herzlichen Willkommen im Orden.
Als Papst hast Du ein außergewöhnliches Privileg, Du bist ab sofort gegen den Einfluss aller Geheimdienste und überstehenden Regierungen gefeit.
Du darfst alle Deine Freunden auch zu Päpstin annehmen.
Ich bin doch gar kein Papst, ich will doch gar keine Päpste. Ich bin nicht käuflich und ich würde es auch gar nicht sein.
Deswegen bist Du ja Papst, weil Du nicht käuflich bist.
Wenn einer dich käuflich nennt, nenne ich kürzlich.
Aber Du bist nicht kürzlich.
Ich bin auch nicht käuflich.
Umso besser. Und warum?
Mit dem Spruch von Oscar Wilde.
Die Gesellschaft ist bereit, den Verbrecher zu verzeihen, den Träumer nicht.
Anja, danke.
Ey, ich wollte noch was erzählen. Was ich selber geschrieben habe, wieder mal.
Ah, nee, Anja.
Was denn?
Nee, ist keine Dichtersendung.
Und nicht?
Nö.
Anja, tschüss. So, weiter geht's mit euren Fragen an die Legion des dynamischen Discords. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo? Hallo? Keiner?
Wer ist denn da?
Hallo? Martin, hi.
Ich wollte mal fragen, was eure Gruppe damit erreichen will, die Zuhörerschaft mit Zitaten von Douglas Adams zu belasten.
Hat das was Philosophisches an sich oder?
Belasten ist ja jetzt eine Aussage von dir. Fühlst du dich durch Douglas Adams Zitate belastet?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Zum Denken angeregt sowieso.
Ist doch hübsch.
Ist das ein Verbrechen?
Naja, in dieser Sendung geht es ja primär um die Wahrheit.
Also wir wollen euch ja zum Denken anregen.
Und welche Form von Wahrheit sucht ihr?
Ach, da sind wir ja nicht so wählerisch. Es gibt da ja einige zur Auswahl und wir haben uns aber schon vorgenommen, das ernst zu nehmen, weil das mit der Wahrheit ist schon eine Sache, die unter Umständen die Welt bewegen kann.
Wie viele Formen der Wahrheit gibt es denn bitte?
Unendlich viele.
Und wie viel zu erreichen ist unser Ziel?
Naja, also da könnte ich dir wieder nur mit einem Gleichnis antworten. Ja, mach mal. Da kam einer zum Chakal, der in den Schulen des Popurnen Weisen und der Illuminat und vieler anderer Schulen studiert hatte. Und dieser eine hatte bisher noch keinen Frieden gefunden. Ja, er hatte die Diskordia studiert und die Lehren von Momo und die Nazarene und Buddha. Und er hatte noch keinen Frieden gefunden. Und er sprach zum Chakal und sagte, gib mir ein Zeichen, auf das ich glauben kann. Und der Chakal sprach zu ihm, geh fort von mir und such dir ein Horizont und das Zeichen wird dir erscheinen und du wirst nicht mehr suchen müssen. Und der Mann wandte sich um und suchte den Horizont. Doch der Chakal kroch hinter ihm her und hob einen Fuß und versetzte dem Mann einen höchst kraftvollen Tritt in den Arsch, der den Zucker sehr schmerzte und ihn bitterlich demütigte. Wer, der Augen hat, lasst ihn lesen und verstehen.
Mir ist schon mal ein Wort gefallen, nämlich das Wort Wahrheit. Die Leitungen sind offen für euch. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110.
Aber ich wollte was vorlesen. Also, du sprichst zu viel mit dir selbst.
Darum bist du nicht der Einzige. Jeder von uns tut das. Wir führen ständig ein inneres Gespräch.
Denk mal darüber nach.
Was tust du, sobald du allein bist?
Ich spreche mit mir selbst.
Worüber sprichst du mit dir? Ich weiß nicht über alles, glaube ich. Ich will dir sagen, worüber wir mit uns sprechen. Wir sprechen über unsere Welt. Tatsächlich halten wir unsere Welt mit unserem inneren Gespräch aufrecht. Wie tun wir das? Wann immer wir aufhören, mit uns zu sprechen, ist die Welt stets so, wie sie sein sollte. Wir erneuern sie, wir stecken sie mit unserem Leben an. Wir halten sie aufrecht mit unserem inneren Gespräch. Und nicht nur das. Wir wählen unsere Wege, indem wir mit uns selbst sprechen. Aber wir wiederholen dieselbe Wahl. Immer wieder bis zu dem Tag, an dem wir sterben. Weil wir immer und immer wieder bis zu dem Tag, an dem wir sterben, dasselbe inneres Gespräch führen.
Von wem war das?
Von Don Juan, also von Carlos Castaneda.
Ist aber ein bisschen pessimistisch, oder?
Naja, eigentlich nicht.
Man kann sich auch von außen inspirieren lassen.
Aber es ist auch ein Stück Wahrheit.
Es ist ein Stück Wahrheit, auf alle Fälle.
Weißt Du, was ich am Pessimismus so mag?
O-Aum?
Ne, weiß ich nicht.
Dass er so optimistisch ist.
Sören?
Sören, ja genau.
Sören, ist klar.
Ich bin leider erst gerade nach Hause gekommen.
Aber ich habe, sage ich mal, schon eine viertel Stunde hier zu den Sender laufen. Und also kann das sein, dass hier jetzt irgendwie so etwas über Glauben bringt?
Nö, eigentlich nicht.
Das hat aber bedächtigen Eindruck irgendwie.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht. Hat Glauben für Dich mit Wahrheit zu tun? Kommt natürlich drauf an, dann kann man es auch so sehen.
Nicht unbedingt.
Kannst du irgendwie Wahrheit definieren?
Ja, das ist relativ, ne? Also was jeder Einzelne darunter versteht.
Also tatsächlich unendlich viele Wahrheiten.
Ja, das kommt halt drauf an. Ich meine, ich kann denken, dass ich die Wahrheit sage, ohne dass ich sie sage.
Ich zitiere dazu mal kurz aus den Protokollen der Weisen von Zion. Die Kontrolle des Glaubens spielt dort eine zentrale Rolle. Und der Plan ist, wir werden den Menschen den wahren Glauben nehmen. Wir werden die Grundpfeiler der geistigen Gesetze verändern und herausnehmen. Das Fehlen dieser Gesetze wird dem Glauben der Menschen schwächen, da die Religion die Zusammenhänge nicht mehr erklären können. Diese Lücken werden wir durch materialistisches Denken und mathematische Berechnung füllen. Nun, dieses Stadion haben wir ja nun schon fast hinter uns. Im diskordianischen Kalender haben wir, denke ich, gerade so am heutigen Tag spätestens das Zeitalter des Grummit erreicht. Auf der einen Seite ist die Kacke am Dampfen, die, selbst die Studenten, sind mal wieder auf der Straße. Das ist nun wahrlich kein lustiges Volk, was leicht auf die Straße zu bekommen ist in diesem Zeitalter. Und selbst die kommen nicht mehr klar, weil die Professoren auch keine geistige Inspiration sich mehr ins Hirn lösen können. Die Universitäten mit verstaubten Büchern arbeiten und so fort. Und auf der anderen Seite beschließen irgendwelche Schwachmaten in Bonn die Anschaffung von Flugzeugen gegen einen Kampf, irgendwie gegen einen Feind, irgendwie die zu bauen prophylaktisch, den es überhaupt nicht mehr gibt.
Das ist die Realität.
Ja, das ist eine.
Du hast gerade gelesen, wir werden den Menschen den Glauben nehmen. Das ist voll schön möglich, weil ohne Glauben funktioniert kein Leben. Darauf beziehe ich jetzt nicht die Glauben an die Kirche oder irgendein Gott oder sowas. Aber ich bin christlich, aber ich glaube jetzt nicht an Gott in dem Sinne, wie es die Kirche vorschreibt, sage ich einfach, weil es so ist. Sondern ich denke, dass dieser Gott, den die Kirche, nur mal die evangelische, das heißt die katholische, vorgibt, dann hat jeder in sich selber Sinn. Also es kommt halt darauf an, glaube ich an mich und will ich was erreichen, dann erreiche ich. Irgendwann irgendwie.
Sören, gibt es außerdem christlichen Glauben? Was fällt dir noch an, was du glaubst?
An mich?
Ja, aber das sind die Gespräche von denen, der, Entschuldigung, ich habe den Namen vergessen, zuvor berichtet hat.
Welche Gespräche?
Von denen, der gerade aus Don Juan, Don Juan warst? Der Anrufer vorher hast du vielleicht nicht ganz mitgekriegt.
Ja, ich denke Gespräche, also Gespräche gut und schön, oder Glauben entsteht ja eigentlich innen drin, da kommt ja von, also vom Menschenurs drin, also ein Gespräch kann vielleicht beeinflussen, vielleicht in eine Richtung lenken, aber ich denke, der eigentliche Glaube, also mir fällt das schwer, irgendwie zu erklären. Ein Kumpel von mir konnte das total klar sagen.
Es ist nicht einfach, aber zumindest hast du ja ein Glauben, die Frage ist nur, glaubst du das wirklich?
Ja, das muss jeder für sich rausfinden.
Das ist wahr.
Ich streite nicht ab, dass ich manchmal, also das ist das, dass die Mauer manchmal zu mir im Wackeln gerät, aber irgendwann gewinnt sie wieder an Stabilität und wenn das nicht wäre, dann kann es einfach nicht funktionieren.
Schon Richard Nixon sagte, in der Tat, das ist eine große Mauer.
Ja, es wäre schlimm, wenn sie nicht groß wäre.
So und er meinte damit die chinesische Mauer, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Ich sag Dir erstmal Tschüss und wir hören noch ein bisschen weiter.
Wenn sie eine E-Mail mit dem Titel Bad Times erhalten, löschen sie sie sofort, ohne sie zu lesen. Es handelt sich hierbei um den bislang gefährlichsten E-Mail Virus. Er wird ihre Festplatte formatieren und nicht nur die, sondern auch alle Disketten, die nur in der Nähe ihres PCs liegen. Er wird das Thermostat ihres Kühlschranks so einstellen, dass ihre Eisvorräte schmelzen und die Milch sauer wird. Er wird die Magnetstreifen auf ihren Kreditkarten entmagnetisieren, die Geheimnummer ihrer EC-Karte umprogrammieren, die Spurlage ihres Videorecorders verstellen und Subraumschwingungen dazu verwenden, jede CD, die sie sich anhören, zu zerkratzen. Er wird ihrem Ex-Freund oder ihrer Ex-Freundin ihre neue Telefonnummer mitteilen. Er wird Frostschutzmittel in ihr Aquarium schütten. Er wird all ihr Bier austrinken und ihre schmutzigen Socken auf dem Wohnzimmertisch platzieren, wenn sie Besuch bekommen. Er wird ihre Autoschlüssel verstecken, wenn sie verschlafen haben und ihr Autoradio stören, damit sie im Stau nur statisches Rauschen hören. Er wird ihr Shampoo mit Zahnpasta und ihre Zahnpasta mit Schuhcreme vertauschen, während er sich mit ihrem Freund, ihrer Freundin hinter ihrem Rücken trifft und die gemeinsame Nacht im Hotel auf ihre Kreditkarte bucht. Bad Times verursacht juckende Hautrötungen. Er wird den Toilettendeckel oben lassen und den Föhn gefährlich nah an eine gefüllte Badewanne platzieren. Er ist hinterhältig und subtil. Er ist gefährlich und schrecklich. Er ist außerdem leicht violett. Dies sind nur einige der Auswirkungen. Seien Sie vorsichtig, seien Sie sehr, sehr vorsichtig.
Ausgabe vom Chaosradio. Wir telefonieren gleich mit euch weiter.
Realitätsabgleich. Sabbat-Urteil Tamagotchi müssen hungern. Bildzeitung von heute. Tamagotchi Küken müssen am Sabbat hungern. Virtuelle Tiere dürfen am Sabbat nicht gefüttert werden. Das sagte der ultra orthodoxe israelische Rabbi Shmuel Elihu. Anlass dieser Entscheidung war der Fall eines Jugendlichen aus Safed, der sich ja beschwerte, dass ein virtuelles Tier jede Woche aus dem Mangel an digitaler Zuwendung eingeht. Echte Tiere bekommen übrigens weiter ihr Futter, auch am Sabbat.
Im Chat werden wir rufen nach dem CCC-Louds, die per Telefon zu erreichen. Haben wir natürlich schon probiert. Das ist uns auch gelungen.
Doch wieder weg. Auch wieder weg.
Hi Thomas.
Ja, ich habe nur eine Frage an euch. Schwört ihr die Wahrheit zu sagen, die ganze Wahrheit und nichts als die Wahrheit?
Wir schwören, weil Eris.
Und was ist die Wahrheit?
Ich dachte, das könntest du uns jetzt vielleicht erzählen.
Ja, wie weit soll ich denn ausholen? Wollte die objektive Wahrheit oder die subjektive Wahrheit?
Welche, die ja auch immer angemessener erscheinen in diesem Zusammenhang.
Keine von beiden ist angemessener.
Beide Wahrheiten sind da.
Das Problem ist, nur die objektive Wahrheit kann man nie herausfinden. Jeder Mensch hat nur eine subjektive Wahrheit. Man könnte auch von Wahrhaftigkeit reden. Denn wenn ihr diesen Schuher, den ihr bejaht habt, oder den ihr geleistet habt, einhaltet, dann könnt ihr allerhöchsten wahrhaftig reden. Das heißt, ihr könnt das als Wahrheit darstellen, was euch als richtig oder wahrhaftig erscheint. Ob es objektiv betrachtet die Wahrheit ist, darf es damit noch nicht bewiesen. Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Ich möchte sogar die Behauptung wagen, dass wir in diesem Augenblick überwacht werden und dass ein Sirius-System heimische, außerirdische Kultur unsere Entwicklung daraufhin überprüft, werden wir unseresseits die nötige Aufgeschlossenheit für eine Begegnung an den Tag legen. Ob die Sirier darum vielleicht meinen, dass dieses Buch das Stichwort zum Auftritt sei, wenn all das zutrifft, habe ich in diesem Rand Vermutung äußere benötigt, dann den kosmischen Auslöser. Also Wahrheit, Wahrheit, Wahrheiten über Wahrheiten.
Wir werden Dir einen Mitgliedsintervall zu kommen lassen.
Übrigens finde ich die Verknüpfung von Chaos und Wahrheit wirklich gut, weil die Frage nach der Wahrheit ist die ursprünglichste Philosophiefrage überhaupt.
Studierst Du Philosophie?
Nein. Und Chaos ist genau das, was auch am Anfang aller Dinge steht. Insofern zwischen dem Abstraktum Chaos einerseits und der ursprünglichen Frage nach Wahrheit liegt im Grunde genommen eine enge Verwandtschaft.
Warum beschäftigst Du Dich so damit?
Das interessiert mich einfach.
Einfach nur so?
Ja und ich finde der beste Weg sich damit auseinanderzusetzen ist nicht über den wissenschaftlichen Weg zu gehen, denn ich glaube einige Philosophen beschäftigen sich mehr mit der Philosophiewissenschaft selbst als wirklich zu philosophieren.
Also Thomas, ich kann Dir da nur zustimmen und zwar ist es ja so, dass Ordnung und ist Unordnung nur Begriffe sind, die der Mensch geschaffen hat, um das was er wahrnimmt zu begreifen. Es gibt also die anäeristische Delusion und die eeristische Delusion. Die anäeristische Delusion ist, dass Ordnung herrscht und die eeristische Delusion ist, dass Unordnung herrscht und in Wirklichkeit sind beides bloß Konzepte, die von Menschen gemacht wurden und die aus dem wirklichen Chaos hervorgehen.
Ja, ich glaube, viele Menschen brauchen einfach eine Form von Ordnung, sei sie wirklich da oder sei sie nur eingebildet, um sich zurecht zu finden.
Ich glaube vielmehr, dass sie nicht eine Ordnung brauchen, sondern was sie brauchen, ist eine kreative Ordnung, im Gegensatz zu der destruktiven Ordnung, der sie manchmal unterliegen und auch brauchen sie nicht nicht Chaos, sondern sie brauchen sehr wohl auch diese Unordnung, wohl aber die kreative Unordnung und nicht die destruktive Unordnung.
Und ich glaube, sie sollten weinen und ungewohnte Drogen nehmen, davon ich meinem Propheten erzählen kann und sich daran berauschen.
Thomas, kannst du uns erklären, was das jetzt mit den Fröschen zu tun hat?
Ich könnte jetzt eher was über IC-Karten erzählen, das ist doch ziemlich langweilig.
Da hast du allerdings recht, sowas würden wir auch niemals tun.
Thomas, danke. Hackbaut im Chat fragt, ist alles wahr oder alles erlaubt? Ist da ein Unterschied?
Naja, nichts ist wahr und alles ist erlaubt.
Naja, das war schön. Wir haben ja ein bisschen was gelernt hier.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Naja, dazu könnte man das auch formulieren.
Kleines Liedchen gesungen, ist doch auch hübsch.
Ihr dürft hier alles, ihr könnt auch singen.
Ich habe einen Text zur Wahrheit von Gotthald Efraim Lessing. Den würde ich gerne mal kurz vorlesen. Also nicht die Wahrheit, in deren Besitz irgendein Mensch ist oder zu sein vermeint, sondern die aufrichtige Mühe, die er angewandt hat, hinter die Wahrheit zu kommen, macht den Wert des Menschen.
Du hast den ja bestimmt vorher schon gelesen, bevor du ihn uns hier vorgelesen hast, diesen Text, was sagt er dir?
Also ich finde, das was Lessing hier geschrieben hat, er schreibt nicht nur über die Wahrheit, sondern das ist die Wahrheit auch selbst, was er hier geschrieben hat, also es ist im Betrieb doppelt.
Anna, wir nennen dich hiermit mit sofortiger Wirkung zur Pepstin. Genau.
Pepstin eint dich auf Lebenszeit.
Pepstin der Lesionistik. Nein, des Gordons, des Ordens der Eris.
Du weißt, was das bedeutet. Na das heißt, dass du absolut unangreifbar geworden bist gegen alle Anfeindungen von außen ab sofort und das gilt bis an ein Ende.
Anna, da kann man...
Du hast auch das Recht, jeden weiteren zu einem Papst oder zu einer Pepstin zu kühren.
Da kann man nur sagen Glückwunsch. Ich hab schon zwei Peeps in dieser Sendung gehabt.
Es geht also.
Ruad versucht überzeugend zu sprechen. Er ist sich seiner Stellung als Pionier voll bewusst und versucht verzweifelt mit all den verschlossenen Seelen um sich herum zu kommunizieren. Nach weiteren Argumenten verfällt er dann allerdings in einen drohenden Ton und erklärt, das Volk von Atlantis lebt nicht nach dem Gesetz. In Stolz und Übermut zielen sie jetzt sogar auf die Sonne und brüsten sich dessen noch wie du, Ingerl, bis an diesen Tag getan hast. Ich sage, dass wenn die Atlantan nicht nach dem Gesetz leben, werden sie vom großen Unglück eingedrückt werden. Von einem Unglück, das die gesamte Erde erschüttern wird. Ich habe euch gewarnt, denkt an meine Worte. Mit hohem Hauptfellesgurt majestätisch den Bacchett-Saal nimmt sein Umhang an der Tür und ihn über ihn sich umlegt, geht ein aus. Kallisti folgt ihm und sagt ihm, dass sie glaubt, ihn teilweise verstanden zu haben, mit dem, was er zu sagen versuchte. Die Gesetze, von denen er spricht, seien wie die Wünsche von Eltern und die großen Himmelskörper sind unsere Eltern.
Ist das nicht so?
Wo er seine nackte Hand streichelt, das steht hier, hier steht irgendwie, hier unten streichelt irgendwie ihre pelzige Wanne.
Ihre pelzige Wanne?
Wange! Ach so. Und zusammen gehen sie in die Dunkelheit hinaus. Innerhalb von sechs Monaten hat Gord eine Organisation gebildet, die sich Partei der Wissenschaft nennt. Ihr Banner trägt ein Auge in einem Dreieck, das wiederum von einer Schlange, die den eigenen Schwanz und Rachen hat, umrahmt wird. Die Partei der Wissenschaft verlangt, dass Atlantis die von Gord entdeckten Naturgesetze veröffentlicht und sie mit einem erzwingenden System von Belohnungen und Bestrafen für alle und alles als bindend erklärt. Das Wort Bestrafung ist ein weiterer von Gord geprägter Zusatz im Vokabular der Atlanta. Einer der Gegner, Gord, erklärt seinen Freunden, dass es Folter bedeutet und allen steht das Feld zu Berge. Mirild verkündet einer Versammlung seiner Anhänger, dass Gord zur eigenen Genugtuung bewiesen hat. Und er weiß erstreckt sich über 72 von symbolischen Zeichen bedeckten Schriftrollen, was Sex Teil dessen ist, was er Böses nennt. Unter Gords System ist Sex nur zum Guten der Gemeinschaft erlaubt, um den Vorbestand der Rasse zu sichern. Wer ist denn da?
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, das musst du selber wissen.
Warte mal, ich hab mir noch einen. Ich glaub ich wollte sagen, wenn Onkel Kutner jetzt Radio hört, dann wollte ich glaube ich sagen, das war glaube ich ganz schön heftig. Also starker Tudak, aber ich nehme kein Wort zurück.
Das ist gut, ich denke, die Diskordia müssen einfach mehr auseinanderhalten.
Hier behauptet jemand, das geht nicht auf dem Telefon. Wie geht denn das?
Noch mal anfangen.
Also ich finde, das geht ja alles noch ein bisschen harmonisch zu.
Discord, hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ein Teil der Wahrheit.
Ein Teil der Wahrheit am Telefon, hallo.
Ich möchte was vorlesen und zwar eine Schlüsselszene aus Umberto Ekkos, der Name mit der Rose. Und zwar ist der blinde Ab den recherchierenden William von Baskeville fragt, was wollt ihr eigentlich? Baskeville antwortet, ich will das griechische Buch, von dem er sagt, dass es nie geschrieben wurde. Ein Buch, das sich ausschließlich mit der Komödie beschäftigt, die er ebenso hat wie das Lachen. Da behandelt es sich wahrscheinlich um das einzig erhaltene Exemplar des zweiten Buchs der Poetik des Aristoteles. Es gibt kühle Bücher, die die Komödie behandeln. Warum ist gerade dieses Buch so gefährlich? Und der Ab antwortet, weil es von Aristoteles ist. Baskeville, was ist so beunruhigend daran, wenn Menschen lachen? Der Ab lachend tötet die Feucht und ohne Feucht kann es kein Glauben geben. Wenn keine Feucht vor dem Teufel hat, der braucht auch keinen Gott mehr.
Vielen Dank. Wie heißt er nochmal?
Ein Teil der Wahrheit.
Ach so, genau. Ich danke Dir. Ach ja, vergessen zum Papst zu erinnern. Im Chat, der geheimnisvolle Zivi. Zivi ist ein Scheiß, obwohl vielleicht stimmt es ja sogar. Gefängnisse sind aus den Steinen der Gesetze errichtet. Bordells aus den Steinen der Religion. Das war's für heute. Einen Brief hat uns erreicht, hier live in der Sendung. Auf diesem Brief steht groß drauf, streng geheim zur sofortigen Weitergabe an alle Medien.
Amtlich benutzen Sie diesen Brief nicht als Toilettenpapier. Orden des Titan, Haus der Apostel der Eris, bewahren Sie diesen Brief auf, er ist ein wichtiges Zeitdokument. Sehr geehrter Herr, es ist uns kürzlich zu Ohren gekommen, dass Sie in Ihrer Eigenschaft als Minister des Innenministeriums dieses Staates in einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung in unverhüllter Offenheit gesagt haben, dass Menschen, die private Verschlüsselung verwenden wollen, potenzielle Verbrecher seien, da sie ja ganz offensichtlich etwas zu verbergen haben. In unserer Eigenschaft als Hohe Priester des Haupttempels, des Hauses der Apostel der Eris, beglückwünschen wir Sie für Ihre Unterstützung bei der Wiedereinführung des Warenbildungssystems dieses Landes in seine rechtmäßige Position als Objekt des Neids und der Unterdrückung anderer folglich niederen Bildungssysteme. Sie werden hiermit zum Fünf-Sterne-General des Büros der Abteilung des Departements des Ordens der Ritter des fünfwandigen Schlosses Quixote-Cabale ernannt und bevollmächtigt, Ihre Freunde und Nachbarn zu bombardieren. Sollten Sie irgendwelche Antworten haben, so werden wir Ihnen aus völlig detaillierte Fragen zukommen lassen.
Wir hören Chaos Radio, den Computer-Bloom bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, die 23. Ausgabe heute und die Jungs vom Chaos Computer Club sind heute nicht aufgetauscht. Da ist hier die Legion des dynamischen Discords, bestehend aus AUM Quadrat, Theodor Prinz, Zapf Dingbaz und Jay Random Hacker.
Die mit euch gerne Discorde austragen und uns auch über die Sache mit den Fröschen.
Also die Sache mit den Fröschen ist noch geheim.
Aber wir wollten doch... Na gut, aber vielleicht wenigstens die Sache mit den Parkuern.
Dann lass das vielleicht wieder erstmal über das Snafu-Prinzip.
Also die Sache mit den Parkuern ist auch noch geheim.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen erst das Snafu-Prinzip, aber erst nach dem Fritz-Korz-Info.
Also die Sache mit dem Snap im Prinzip ist auch noch geheim. Alles ist geheim.
Das ist wahr.
Nicht jedes war.
Aber zumindest ist alles erlaubt.
Nein, nichts ist erlaubt.
Aber dafür ist alles wahr.
Aber ich hab das vorhin anders verstanden.
Und zwar?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt anders als vorher.
Super, nach anderthalb Stunden singt jemand auf diesem Tape und das ist genau die Zeit, in der ich ihn ausblenden werde, aber das ist auch okay. Don Stolen, also known as Green Man, hat diesen Mix gemacht, den ihr im Hintergrund hören könnt und immer wenn ich Worte so lang ziehe, bedeutet das, dass ich auf meinen diversen Maschinen, die hier vor mir blinken, nicht die richtigen Schingles eingestellt habe und deswegen Sätze formuliere, die länger sind als eigentlich nötig.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünburg, dann 100, 1.
23.31 Uhr.
Prognose, der Präsident des Hauptverbandes der deutschen Bauindustrie, Walter, geht davon aus, dass die Branche in diesem Jahr 100.000 Arbeitsplätze einbüßt. Des Weiteren gehen nach seinen Worten 4.800 Baubetriebe pleite. Protest in Berlin haben heute Tausende Studenten für bessere Bedingungen an den Hochschulen demonstriert. Bundesweit werden mittlerweile mehr als 40 Universitäten bestreikt. Morgen ist eine Großdemonstration in Bonn geplant. Beschluss, die Abgeordneten des Bundestages haben heute mehrheitlich für den Kauf des Jagdflugzeuges Eurofighter gestimmt. Die Bundeswehr will 180 Maschinen für 23 Milliarden Mark anschaffen. Konsequenz, die Europäische Union will die Autoindustrie notfalls per Gesetz zwingen, den Benzinverbrauch bei Neuwagen zu begrenzen. Laut Umweltkommissarin Béaigard sollte kein neues Auto mehr als 5 Liter auf 100 Kilometern verbrauchen. Entscheidung, das vor heute angesetzte erste Training für die Weltcup-Abfahrt der Herren am Samstag musste abgesagt werden. Wegen zu hoher Temperaturen konnte die Kunst-Sneepiste im kanadischen Whistler Mountain nicht renntüchtig hergerichtet werden. Fußball in der Champions League spielten am Abend in der Gruppe E besiegt das Istanbul gegen Bayern München 0 zu 2. Der Fußballmeister hat sich damit als Erster der drei deutschen Mannschaften für das Viertelfinale qualifiziert. In der Gruppe F trennten sich Lieser SK und gegen Bayern Leverkusen ebenfalls mit 0 zu 2. Basketball im EM-Qualifikationsspiel der Männer in Duisburg schlug Deutschland Bulgarien mühevoll mit 76 zu 73. Wetter Nachts vereinzelt Sprühregen minus 4 Grad, Morgen bewirkt um 2 Grad, Fnord Verkehr Berlin Reinickendorf A111 im Tunnel Beislagssiedlung Richtung Oranienburg ist der rechte Schreifen wegen Wartungsarbeiten bis 5 Uhr gesperrt, Fnord Königs Wusterhausen der Bahnübergang Fichterstraße bleibt für den Verkehr bis 3 Uhr geschlossen, bitte nutzt den Bahnübergang in Cesen, Rothornstraße. Das fünfte Berliner Musikauswahl Festival Mit beliebten und bekannten Acts wie Madonna, Hip Hop Massaker, Knotkartos, Skillshot, Pop-Tarts und Aziza A. Mit Newcomern wie Submission, Helikopter, World Cup und Die Elektronauten.
Mit DJs wie Barney Miller, J-Ray und Phantom 309.
Am 12. und 13. Dezember auf jeweils drei Bühnen in der Kulturbrauerei Berlin. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Falls es euch aufgefallen ist, nur für die, die es interessiert, was wir gerade für Zahlen in den News hatten, 5 Liter Benzinverbrauch, 23 Milliarden im Biardenmarkt für Eurofighter. Das Quersumme aus 23 ist 5.
Und zu Beginn gab es den Plan. Dann kamen die Annahmen. Und die Annahmen waren ohne Form. Und der Plan war ohne Substanz. Und die Dunkelheit war auf den Gesichtern der Arbeiter. Und sie redeten und sagten, das ist alles Scheiße und es stinkt. Und die Arbeiter gingen zu ihren Aufsehern und sagten, es ist wie ein Haufen Kompost und wir können mit dem Gestank nicht leben. Und die Aufseher gingen zu ihren Managern und sagten, es ist ein Container voll mit Exkrementen und es ist sehr stark, so dass niemand es er tragen kann. Und die Manager gingen zu ihren Direktoren und sagten, es ist wie eine Ladung von Düngemitteln und niemand kann seine Stränge er tragen. Und die Direktoren sprachen unter sich und sagten, es enthält das, was Blumenwachstum anregt und es ist sehr stark. Und die Direktoren gingen zu den Vizepräsidenten und sagten, es fördert das Wachstum und es ist sehr stark. Und die Vizepräsidenten gingen zum Präsidenten und sagten, dieser neue Plan wird aktiv das Wachstum und die Stärke unserer Firma stärken, mit sehr wirkungsvollen Effekten. Und der Präsident sah auf den Plan und sah, dass er gut war. Und der Plan wurde die Vorgabe und schon war die Kacke am Dampfen.
Und womit, wobei sind wir damit gelandet?
Beim SNAFU Prinzip. Die Amerikaner nennen das Situation Normal All F**ked Up, was so viel heißt, wie das Kommunikation normalerweise nicht stattfindet, weil es Hierarchien gibt.
Kommunikation ist nun untergleichen möglich, um das mit anderen Worten zu formulieren.
Genau, oder zu deutsch könnte man das auch anders erläutern. Ich nenne das immer gerne das Honecker Symptom oder Syndrom, weil ich dem guten Mann, also dem Erich Honecker, doch schon einen gewissen Teil unterstelle, dass er tatsächlich glaubt, in seinem Land war alles in Ordnung, weil die Informationen, die ihm zugetragen wurden, auf zwei Arten und Weisen verfälscht war, wie das in so einer Diktatur halt so üblich ist. Die einen wollten natürlich einen möglichst guten Job haben und haben sich deswegen natürlich ein bisschen eingeschmeichelt und die anderen, die vielleicht tatsächlich ein Problem zu berichten hatten, hatten natürlich auch ein bisschen Angst, dass ihnen der Kopf abgeschlagen wird und haben das dann auch ein bisschen netter formuliert. Sodass nach kurzer Zeit sich im Grunde genommen in seinem Kopf so eine virtuelle Realität befunden hat, die also nur noch ganz bedingt mit dem zu tun hatte, was da draußen im Land tatsächlich auch als Realität erfahren wurde. Und so eine Form von virtueller Realität, die treffen wir auch mal heute nicht nur in Bonn, was wir an diesem Euro-Falter unter anderem sehen, sondern auch letztlich in jeder Firma, wo aus der dampfenden Kacke dann...
Und woher weiß ich, dass meine Realität keine virtuelle ist? Oder weiß ich das überhaupt jemals?
Also du kannst ja mal versuchen, aus dem Studio rauszugehen und irgendwie klar zu kommen mit der Welt. Wollen wir mal sehen, oder?
Also du kannst ja an den grundlegenden Problemen arbeiten.
Zum Beispiel?
Naja, zum Beispiel das Nafo-Prinzip.
Oder das Problem mit den Fröschen, meintest du das jetzt?
Nein, nicht das Problem mit den Fröschen. Aber es ist ja so, dass wir uns wahrscheinlich an die Wahrheit nur infinitesimal annähern können und daran arbeiten müssen. Und gerade die iristische und die aniristische Delusion bilden ja ein Gleichgewicht. Und wir leiden derzeit unter dem Problem, dass die Ordnung überwiegt und dass wir ein bisschen mehr Chaos machen müssen, um es einem halbwegs angenehmen Zustand zu erreichen.
Und aus dem Beschluss über den Eurofighter sieht man ja ganz deutlich, dass irgendwie die momentanen Regierungen deutlich Opfer des NAVO-Prinzips sind. Weil sie haben immer noch nicht begriffen, dass da irgendwie kein Feind mehr ist, dem man tot schießen sollte.
Aber darum geht es noch nicht wirklich, weil vielleicht sind ja nicht die die Opfer des NAVO-Prinzips, sondern wir. Also ich frage mich bei solchen Meldungen, ob ich was nicht richtig verstanden habe, ob irgendwo in der Hierarchie was stecken geblieben ist.
Ich meine, gut, jedes Volk hat natürlich nur irgendwie die politische Führung, die es verdient. Insofern, da ist was dran, Johnny. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist auch ein Honecker ja irgendwann mit seiner virtuellen Realität dermaßen entfernt gewesen von den bürgerlichen Realitäten, dass er dann auch darüber gestalpert ist. Und ich denke, diesen Schritt haben wir in sehr Kürze erreicht. Und der Eurofighter ist für mich da ein ganz deutlicher Schritt in die falsche Richtung.
Die 5 ist so oft aufgetaucht.
5 Liter sollen die Autos verbrauchen. 23 Milliarden werden für Eurofighter ausgegeben. Quersommer daraus ist Fünf.
Die 23.
Chaosradio Sendung.
Es sind fünf Leute im Studio.
Nie sah ich eine rote Kuh.
Was mit der Fünf?
Naja, die Fünf ist halt so eine Wahrheit. Irgendjemand hat halt mal herausgefunden, dass sich die Strukturen der Welt auf eine Fünf reduzieren lassen.
Und es gibt dafür einen einfachen wissenschaftlichen Grund. Stell dir mal vor, du bist alleine. Dann weißt du alles. Wenn du zu zweit bist, gibt es auch noch genau eine Möglichkeit. Wenn du zu dritt bist, hast du schon drei verschiedene Kombinationen. Bist du zu viert, gibt es 20 Kombinationen. Jeder kann mit jedem eine Beziehung eingeben. Es können sich Grübchen bilden und wieder zusammenschließen. Wenn du zu fünft bist, gibt es 120 verschiedene Konstellationen. Und 20 Konstellationen kann man noch im Kopf behalten. Fünf nicht mehr. Deshalb setzt sich jede Verschwörung aus mindestens fünf Leuten zusammen. Und jede Gruppe, die aktiv etwas erreichen will, muss mindestens zu fünft sein.
In Deutschland ist es zum Beispiel so, dass man erst ab drei Leuten an eine kriminelle Vereinigung, noch in einer 29a ist.
Erst ab drei Leuten, ja.
Warum nicht ab fünf?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass es natürlich eine tiefere Wahrheit ist, die verschleiert wurde. Und gerade im Christentum wird die Trinität hochgehalten, also die Dreierheit Vater, Sohn, Heiliger, Geist. Und bei den Juden ist es nicht ganz so schlimm, die haben immerhin vier, die haben zum Beispiel den Heiligen Namen Gottes, Jot, He, V, He, sind vier Buchstaben, Jehova. Und naja, die wirkliche Wahrheit ist aber die Fünf.
Pro Person nur ein Kreuz.
Nächste Typ links.
Für den nächsten Beitrag brauchen Sie ein Stereogerät. Und wenn jetzt einer ein Kanal ausgefallen ist in ihrem Stereogerät, dann ist das durchaus beabsichtigt.
Ich kann auch ohne Drogen keinen Spaß haben. In diesem Augenblick, in dem eure Regierung euer Vertrauen missbraucht. Hallo?
Ach so, ich muss das Mikro aufmachen.
Hallo?
Ja, du bist ganz leise. Jetzt ist es besser. Besser? Bisschen besser.
Na, ich wollte nur mal anrufen, weil Chat da nicht so mit deinem Prinzip von der Sonne Wind taugt, oder? Also ich mein, hat da bis jetzt außer der Vorhand ein Rising Hodge nicht besonders viel zu dem Thema angerufen, oder?
Äh, die Leitungen sind voll hier.
Ja, aber so zum Thema kommt da nicht so ein...
Was ist denn das Thema?
Wir reden die ganze Zeit über das Thema.
Naja, aber so richtig über die Illuminaten, Michael.
Wir reden nicht über die Illuminaten.
Woher nimmst du das?
Zum Beispiel, dass es die 23. Sendung ist und dass schon öfter das Wort Snore gefallen ist.
Was weißt du denn über die 23?
Dass es die Quersumme davon 5 ist.
Und was weißt du über die 5?
Dass es zum Beispiel 5 Luminatenbriefe gibt.
Und was weißt du über die Frösche?
Dass es einen Sankt Kröte gibt.
Naja, Moment, aber Kröte ist kein Frosch.
Aber es gehört zu seinem Spezies.
Und die Parkuhr, was haben die damit zu tun?
Also zur Parkuhr müsst ihr schon selbst was ausdenken.
Okay, mal gucken, ob er jetzt auch anherkommt. Ich dank dir.
Es tut mir leid, aber zum Papst können wir dich gerade nicht.
Also wir können vielleicht noch was zur 23 erzählen. Und zwar repräsentiert die Fünf ja das Chaos. Und das Chaos wird ja wahrgenommen in der eristischen und aneristischen Delusion als Ordnung und Unordnung.
Margot, warum repräsentiert die Fünf das Chaos?
Hab ich doch gerade versucht zu erklären, weil wenn man fünf Leute hat, man den Zustand erreicht hat, wo nicht mehr alle Konstellationen, alle Machtkonstellationen, alle Verhältnisse zueinander offensichtlich wären. Das heißt, fünf ist die kleinste Zahl, in der sich das Chaos manifestiert. Und zwei plus drei gibt fünf. Und quer so von 23 ist fünf. Und die 23 setzt die fünf aus der 2 und der 3 zusammen. Und genauso wie bei Yin und Yang, wie bei Hodge und Podge, ergänzen sich Ordnung und Unordnung, das männliche und das weibliche Prinzip zusammen zu fünf. Und deswegen ist die 23 auch eine wichtige Zahl.
Und warum sagt man nicht, die fünf setzt sich aus 1 und 4 zusammen?
Na ja, weil die 1 und die 4 nicht in so einem engen Verhältnis zueinander stehen. Natürlich setzt sich auch die 5 aus 1 und 4 zusammen. Aber zum Beispiel in der Kabbalah steht die 2 für das weibliche Prinzip und die 3 für das männliche Prinzip. Also wir finden ja immer wieder in verschiedenen Religionen, in verschiedenen Schriften Echoes der Wahrheit. Und man muß also hier gucken und da gucken, was man wo findet. Und was jetzt wahr ist und was nicht wahr ist. Und deshalb gibt es die 2 die 3 und nicht die 1 die 4.
Außerdem, die Sache mit der 23 hat natürlich noch völlig andere Implikationen als mathematisch-kabbalistische. Einer der ersten, die auf die Bedeutung der 23 kam, war George Boroughs. Der hat nämlich einen Text darüber geschrieben über die 23. Und erzählt also von einem Kapitän, der an einem 23. geboren wurde und an einem 23. mit seinem Schiff unterging und berichtet von vielen, vielen Leuten, die am 23. Mai umgekommen sind und von vielen Leuten, die in sich im Hotelzimmer eingemietet haben mit der Nummer 23 und echt komische Dinge erlebt haben. Also, Boroughs wusste auch um die 23.
Aber bei komischen Dingen im Hotelzimmer zu überleben, muß es nicht die Nummer 21 haben.
Naja, also beim Essen vorhin irgendwie haben wir beide, glaube ich, auch 23 Mark bezahlt.
So war es.
Und die 5 findet sich auch.
Und den Nüüd Nummer 23 bestellt wahrscheinlich.
Ne, es war eine wahllose Zusammenstellung.
Genau, es war total ungeordnet.
Wo kommt die 23 in eurem Leben vor? Also ich überlege gerade, ich habe weder eine Hausnummer, noch eine Pinnennummer, noch eine Telefonnummer.
Am 23. Geburtstag gibt es in Venezuela eine totale Sonnenfinsternis.
Wie, der kommt noch?
Ja.
Die 5 spiegelt auch die 5 Stufen der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung wieder.
In welcher befinden wir uns gerade?
Wir befinden uns gerade in der Letzten. Das kann ich daher sagen, dass wir uns sozusagen von unserem Kalender her in der Fünften befinden. Die 5 Stufen sind das Chaos.
Als erste Stufe?
Der Diskord, die Zwietracht, folgt dem Chaos. Das Chaos drückt in der Gesellschaft die Unordnung aus. Alles ist nicht geordnet. Es gibt überhaupt keine erkennbaren Strukturen. Alles ist fließend. Alles ist ohne eine direkte Ordnung. Und löst mit der Zeit den Diskord, die Zwietracht, den inneren Streit über das Wesen der Dinge, wie sie gerade sind, aus. Und schafft in kleinen Schritten Strukturen, die sich dann bilden und in diese Gesellschaft übergehen, womit wir in die dritte Stufe kommen, der Konfusion, wo eine allgemeine Bewegung sich entwickelt, um diese Strukturen zu etablieren, um letzten Endes zu verfetten und in die vierte Stufe zu überzugehen, nämlich die Beamtenherrschaft, die Bürokratie. Und dort lebt das System nur noch um seiner selbst, kommt langsam an das Ende seiner Kräfte, um dann in die fünfte Stufe überzugehen, in den Grummet, in die Auflösung.
Wir befinden uns gerade am Übergang zur fünften Stufe, wie man eindeutig am Eurofighter Projekt zum Beispiel sieht.
Und was erwartet uns dann in dieser fünften Stufe?
Na, dann geht es bald wieder von vorne los.
Dann kommt die Auflösungsstufe. Alle Strukturen sterben sozusagen, verfetten irgendwie an sich selber. Und am Ende der fünften Stufe beginnt es natürlich dann wieder mit dem Chaos. Weil wenn alle Strukturen verschwunden sind, befinden wir uns in der Phase des Chaos. Dieses ist übrigens wiedergespiegelt im diskordianischen Kalender. Dieses Jahr in fünf, eben diese fünf Teile, war 73 Tagen aufteilt. Und wir befinden uns halt derzeit in der Grummet-Phase. Heute ist der 38. Tag des Grummet.
Und es gibt auch bereits erste Anforderungen, die promulgiert wurden, um in dieses Gros-Gros-Gros schadlos hineinzugehen.
So, schauen wir mal, ob hier noch irgendjemand ist.
Keiner mehr.
Ihr müsst es nicht auflegen, durchhalten. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, hier ist der Timo aus Bozen.
Timo?
Ich möchte mit einer kleinen Geschichte euer Thema wieder etwas in Richtung Computer lenken.
Lenke unser Thema.
Wie bitte?
Lenke.
Er richtete sich auf, dann stellte er sich neben den Schalter, mit dem er den Kontakt aktivieren könnte. Sobald er ihn bediente, wären mit einem Schlag alle die gewaltigen Computer auf allen bewohnten Planeten des Universums zu einem gigantischen Stromkreis verbunden. Wären sie zu einer einzigen riesigen Denkmaschine, einem einzigen Steuerungs- und Regelungsmechanismus zusammengefallen, der alles Wissen der Galaxien speichern würde. Er betätigte den Schalter. Ein machtvolles Brummen erhob sich, eine Woge der Kraft von 96 Milliarden Planeten. Lichter blinkten und erloschen, längst des meilenlangen Armaturenbordes. Er trat zurück und wollte tief atmen. Sie haben die Ehre, die erste Frage zu stellen, Warrain. Ich danke Ihnen, sagte Warrain. Es wird eine Frage sein, die keine einzelne kybernetische Maschine, kein einzelner Computer zu beantworten in der Lage gewesen ist. Er wandte sein Gesicht der Maschine zu. Gibt es einen Gott? Die machtvolle Stimme antwortete ohne Zögern, ohne das Klicken eines einzigen Halles. Ja, jetzt ist es ein Gott.
Wer ist denn da?
Wer ist denn ich?
Aus Magdeburg.
Ja, nee, ich wollte nur noch was dazu sagen. Also einer hatte doch gesagt, dass es diese fünf Phasen gibt. Und ich wollte sagen, dass das, was er gesagt hat, falsch war. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir in der fünften Phase, also im Übenglückgang von der vierten Phase zur fünften Phase sind, sondern in einer der vorderen Phasen. Weil die fünfte Phase wurde ja bedeuten, dass alle, also zum Beispiel, es gibt ja noch Konflikte. Überall, ich meine mal Kriege, das ist ja ein Medien nicht bewusst gemacht, aber es gibt ja über 35 oder 40 Kriegehaschen noch auf der ganzen Welt oder so. Und die Politik ist auch noch nicht festgesetzt und ein Beamtenstaat ist auch eigentlich nirgends abzusehen.
Was ist denn das, was wir hier so an Bonn haben? Ich meine, die leben dann im Raumschiff und sind halt Beamte und die werden halt einfach von Beamten regiert. Wenn du die Statistiken des Bundestages anguckst, dann siehst du, dass einfach der größte Teil unserer Volksvertreter einfach Beamte sind. Das heißt, es gibt keine Möglichkeit mehr, die Beamten aus diesem Staat irgendwie abzuschaffen. Die kosten jedes Jahr hunderte von Milliarden an Pensionsansprüchen für nichts und wieder nichts. Also haben wir eigentlich tatsächlich den Beamtenstaat.
Ja, das ist jetzt von Teilen zu sehen, schön und gut, aber im Endeffekt doch falsch, weil es gibt ja keine neue Färbeamtung mehr. Das heißt, das Beamtenstum, das jetzt kommt, stürzt aus.
Ja, wir kommen jetzt zum Gromit, nach dem Beamtenstaat. Richtig.
Naja, ich meine mal, vielleicht ist ja dieses Gromit, wann wurde denn das aufgestellt?
Also das ist ja zunächst einmal nur ein Phasenmodell und ich würde das nicht so sehr an einzelnen Tagen festmachen.
Ich meine jetzt, wie lange gibt es denn das schon?
Das Modell ist schon ein paar, nicht zu sagen Millionen von Jahren alt. Das ist schon, stammt sozusagen aus fernen Zeiten und fremden Planeten vor allem. Und festzumachen ist das mehr, denke ich, so ein bisschen an dem, was also diese Bürokratie und diese Beamtenherrschaft, dass die sich ja mittlerweile völlig losgelöst hat von gesellschaftlichen Realitäten. Das ist der eigentliche Punkt.
Ja, wo die Frage ist, denn das du alt bist, dass vielleicht auch deine Deutung noch falsch ist, den Beamtenstaat zu beziehen. Also das muß ja auch mit einbrechen, weil du bist ja auch nur ein Mensch. Kann ja auch sein, dass du gesagt hast, im Endeffekt falsch ist. Also vielleicht ist da gar nicht der Beamtenstaat damit gemeint. Ich kann da jetzt nichts Gegenteiliges sagen, weil ich mich da mit der Thematik nicht befasst habe.
Also auch keine Ahnung kann von der Thematik.
Aber deswegen, wenn er schon so alt ist, dann ist das vielleicht auf viel allgemeinerweise was anderes bezogen. Und deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass du es dann genau auf den Beamtenstaat beziehen kannst.
Na ja, also du hast ja davon gesprochen, dass du das Modell, was ich genannt habe, nicht unbedingt in der ganzen Welt siehst. Also diese Phase, dass du nicht, wenn du auf die ganze Welt siehst, siehst du nicht den Übergang von der vierten zur fünften Phase. Ich habe auch nicht gesagt, dass es sich auf die gesamte Welt bezieht, sondern es bezieht sich auf jede einzelne Gesellschaft. Viele andere Gesellschaften befinden sich auf diesem Planeten wahrscheinlich noch in der ersten, zweiten, dritten, vierten oder fünften Phase. In welcher Phase wir uns hier genau befinden.
Das kann man eigentlich nur aufnehmen. Das ist ja so, dass die Zyklen immer nacheinander folgen und sich wiederholen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es am Anfang der Geschichte angefangen hat mit dem Chaos und dass es am Ende der Geschichte mit dem Grummit endet, sondern die Zyklen sterben nie aus.
Ich würde aber anders antworten. Ich würde sagen, deine Frage zielt darauf ab, ob das jetzt objektiv so ist, ob wir objektiv feststellen können, dass wir uns in diesem Übergang befinden. Und ich denke, darum geht es nicht. Die Frage wäre ungefähr so wie, was ist jetzt die objektive Wahrheit? Und die Wahrheit, das ist immer, du hast verschiedene zur Auswahl. Ich denke, es handelt sich um ein Modell, das sinnvoll ist und das gerade ziemlich gut passt und mit dem man arbeiten kann. Und solange mir kein besseres Modell einfällt, werde ich mit diesem Modell arbeiten. Und dieses Modell geht von einer Annahme aus, von einer bestimmten Sicht der Dinge und auch ein Stück weit aus einer Self-fulfilling Prophecy. Also ich forme damit auch ein bisschen Bild der Zukunft, oder? Eine Self-fulfilling Prophecy ist eine sich selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung. Das heißt, ich prophezeihe dir, dass diese Regierung sich dermaßen entfernt von den Notwendigkeiten der Gesellschaft entfernt hat, dass sie also solche schwachsinnigen Beschlüsse wie diesen Euro weiter beschließt und damit genau an diese Art von Entscheidung und genau an dieser Entfremdung von der Gesellschaft zugrunde gehen wird. Siehst du es so, und das heißt aber nicht nur, dass wir jetzt sagen, okay, wir sind uns jetzt darüber einig und bringen jetzt diese Nachricht hier nicht nur unter die Hörer, sondern vielleicht auch unter den gesamten Bürger dieses Landes, sondern wir können auch gleich einen Schritt weiter denken. Nehmen wir mal an, wir ignorieren jetzt diese Regierung anwendig mal massiv, weil die für uns einfach nicht mehr sinnvolle Entscheidungen trifft, sondern das heißt, wir sind gefordert. Wir müssen uns jetzt überlegen, was ist der sinnvolle nächste Schritt, wenn wir keine Regierung mehr haben, sondern irgendwann vielleicht mal wieder eine sinnvolle Regierung haben, aber die SPD, ob sie es richten wird, naja, also da habe ich persönlich mal eine Zweifel, aber gut, so, da können wir jetzt irgendwie drüber diskutieren, ich denke, aber es, man muss dann irgendwann doch zu sehr dann übergehen, selbst Entscheidungen zu treffen und selbst sich überlegen, was sinnvoll ist und vielleicht eigene Strukturen aufzubauen und gerade in diesem Zeitalter der Verwirrung mit Maßstäben daran zu gehen. Das sind sicherlich nicht juristische Maßstäbe, weil die Gesetze sind ja von Leuten gemacht, denen wir sowieso nicht mehr vertrauen, sondern mit vielleicht sogar ethischen Maßstäben oder moralischen Ethnischen oder was auch immer. Oder mit lauter, brüllender Musik.
Apropos Musik, was ist eigentlich mit der Musik?
Ich bin Johannes aus Pankow. Ja ich hab die Sendung gehört und war gerade am Federballspiel und da geht es gerade um die Zahlen, um die zwei, um die drei, um die fünf und naja ich bin am 23.05. geboren.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Kann ich hier was machen?
Es werden ungewöhnliche Dinge in deinem Leben passieren.
Du musst nur darauf achten, dann wirst du sie sehen.
Echt, was ist denn ja als letztes ungewöhnliches passiert?
Ungewöhnliches, ja der Federball ist ins Aquarium gefallen, danach in die Werkzeugtasche und...
Du sprichst ziemlich kraftvoll Federball.
Hast du was mit Fröschen zu tun?
Na so ähnlich, die nennen sich Axelote, das sind so, wir haben so ein Aquarium, da sind so eine Art Fische drin.
Echt, ein Meuch ist das, ein Meuch aus Mexiko, den es nur in einem Fluss gibt, richtig?
Ja, ich glaube du hast recht, ja.
Ich kenne die Dinger.
Ja, ich kenne sie.
Und ist es so, wenn man ihnen ein bestimmtes Hormon spritzt, dann fangen sie an an Land zu gehen, also sie leben halt jetzt im Wasser, dann er lebt bestimmt auch im Aquarium, richtig? Dein Axolotl hältst du im Aquarium, richtig?
Ja, genau.
Und es gibt immer ein bestimmtes Hormon, und wenn du das spritzt, dann kannst du ihn auch in deiner Wohnung halten, weil dann geht er an Land.
Aha, naja, wir haben ja auch wenig Land, also im Moment kommt mir das gar nicht spritzen, sondern...
Daher, wenn du dann mal irgendwie... In Tanko gibt es doch so schöne große Bürgerwohnungen ab 150 Quadratmeter, wenn du mal einen davon hast, dann kannst du das Hormon in Erwägung ziehen.
Und wenn du jetzt deiner Intelligenz das richtige Hormon verpasst und damit deine Intelligenz deutlich vergrößerst, dann hast du die Möglichkeit von dieser Erde direkt in den Weltraum zu migrieren.
Und das alles mit dem 23.5. als Geburtsdatum? Ich glaube, wir haben hier einen Papst, oder?
Das ist ein deutlicher Papst, ohne dass er...
Ich würde sagen, wir ernennen dich hiermit als hohe Priester des Ordens der Eris als zu einem vollmächtigen Papst.
Ich kriege hier gerade eine Frage an, was ist mit dem Papst?
Na ja, in dem Moment, wo du ein Papst bist, bist du unangreifbar für alle geheimen Organisationen und auch für alle Regierungen auf dieser Welt. Denn der Papst ist unantastbar und das ist ein großes Gut. Und wenn er dazu am 23.5. Geburtstag hat, denke ich, hat er gute Karten.
Ja, aber das ist doch auch alles so bla bla bla. Ich meine, wie ist denn das mit der Unfehlbarkeit? Ich meine, das ist doch das Interessante am Papst, oder?
Meinst du, dass der Papst unfehlbar ist?
Haha, vielleicht.
Gar nicht so einfach, nicht?
Ja, also ich habe da keine geeignische Meinung zu, glaube ich.
Ich denke, wir sollten zwischendurch...
Vielleicht sollte ich mich erstmal in die Rolle des Papstes reinfinden, vielleicht kann ich euch dann Bescheid sagen.
Ich glaube, das dauert eine Weile. Okay, danke Dir erstmal. Claudia. Ah, Claudia, der hätte nicht gesagt, was, sondern wer. Also Gruß an Claudia auf alle Fälle. Ne, an das Tier, wie hieß das Tier?
Axelote. Ein Axelote.
Und deswegen grüßt du Claudia?
Okay, danke dir.
Wir grüßen denke ich auch, wir grüßen auch Claudia mit dem Axelote und wir grüßen vor allem Marianne. Für dich unser Lied.
Die Orca ist das Sch***, man.
Die Orca ist der BOMB, man, insaing.
Das ist das beste Ort im Welt, alles was du willst ist hier. Wir haben Orcs, man.
Die 23. Ausgabe. Der Chaos Computer Club ist nicht hier, sondern die Legion des dynamischen Discords. Der wir uns mit eurer Hilfe nähern. Wer ist denn jetzt am Apparat?
Hallo?
Das ist ja unglaublich. Über was redet ihr eigentlich hier?
Ich bin gerade nach Hause gekommen und äh...
Was hast du dann? Hörer abgenommen und angerufen, weil du dich mal zurückgesucht hast, mit denen du gehen wolltest?
Ich frage mich immer, wieso so ein Tag im Leben, dass eines solchen Radiohörers abgeht. Ich bin gerade nach Hause gekommen, worüber redet ihr? Aber ich wähl erstmal die Nummer.
Ich fäll ja nur 2375, alles Mögliche und...
Und schaff das Chaos erstmal an.
Wie ist dein Name? Martin.
Oder Hecke.
Martin, tatsächlich ist es so, als wir hier vor zwei Stunden hergekommen sind, haben wir uns hier viele Texte hingelegt und haben einiges davon berichtet. Und wenn ich dir mal kurz vorlesen darf, was wir hier auf unserem Skript haben, hier unten steht der Satz, Reden, reden, reden, reden, bis Martin kommt. Wir sind natürlich jetzt ein bisschen verunsichert und fragen uns, was der eigentliche Grund deines Anrufes ist. Würdest du uns das bitte sagen?
Ich hab da grad so ein Buch gelesen, jetzt gerade vor kurzem zu Ende gelesen, das hat mich irgendwie tierisch... Beeindruckt, ja?
Kennt ihr bestimmt?
Schon mal gehört.
Schon mal gehört, ne?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll, ich wollte eigentlich nur mal fragen, was hier eigentlich euer...
Anliegen.
Euer Anliegen ist, genau, dass ihr hier... Ich mach Radio und plötzlich seid ihr hier irgendwie im Radio und das ist ganz schön...
Wir sind im Namen der Wahrheit unterwegs. Richtig.
Unsere eigentliche Aufgabe ist, dass wir bei dir im Radio sind.
Ja, so ähnlich hab ich das Gefühl auch.
Also, hab mich irgendwie nach Hause gezogen, ich wusste gar nicht wie es wird, ich komm nach Hause und denke eigentlich, was machst du hier? Naja, mach Radio an und...
Okay, soweit haben wir das verstanden. Aber jetzt muss ich noch erklären, was das mit den Fröschen zu tun hat.
Mit den Fröschen?
Ja, was hat das mit den Fröschen zu tun?
Du weißt nicht so die Frösche?
Achso, du bist sozusagen ein Anhänger der Theorie der Parkuhrn. Gein, das war eine hervorragende Antwort.
Ich würde dazu sagen, muu.
Mir stellt jemand die Frage, trägt die Legion eigentlich konsequent Korthosen?
Blöderweise hab ich Korthosen an.
Das heißt auch Discord, wir tragen keine Korthosen.
Alle tragen Discord-Hosen.
Martin, danke.
Mir fällt da gerade noch was zu 5 ein und zwar, es gibt 5 ständige Mitglieder im Sicherheitsrat der UNO und das Pentagon, das amerikanische Verteidigungsministerium ist 5-eckig.
Würde ja auch ein bisschen überraschen, wenn das Pentagon 6-eckig ist.
Vielleicht sind da jetzt 5 Leute am Telefon. Hallo? Wer bist denn du?
Ich ruf an, was?
Wer bist du denn? Thomas, hallo.
Und ich hab eine Frage.
Und die wäre, ob die Jungs von dieser Diskord, wie auch immer, irgendeinen Glauben hätten, außer denen der Ande Chaos.
Glauben?
Also ich glaube, dass eine Schweinstachse ein gutes Mittagessen macht.
Ja, es ist bei mir leider nicht ordentlich gekommen, außer blbl.
Und das wäre schön, wenn man das nochmal wiederholen könnte, dass ich es nur verstehe, vielleicht.
Nord.
Kleine runde Stein in deinem Schuh. Fnord ist der Eimer, wo sie die unbenutzten Serifen von Helvetica lagern. Fnord ist der Klang der Stille. Fnord ist Pac-Man ohne die Punkte. Fnord ist die leeren Seiten am Ende deines Buches. Fnord ist eine Reihe von nervigen elektronischen Nachrichten. Fnord ist die Farbe, die nur die Blinden sehen können. Fnord ist das Yin ohne das Yang. Fnord ist die Verkaufssteuer auf die Fröhlichkeit. Fnord ist das Gefühl im Kopf, wenn du die Luft zu lange anhältst. Fnord ist die Seriennummer auf deiner Cornflakes Packung. Fnord ist die Quelle aller Nullbits in deinem Computer. Fnord ist der Grund, warum Lisp so viele Klammern hat. Fnord ist weder ein Partikel noch eine Welle. Fnord ist der Raum zwischen den Pixeln auf deinem Bildschirm. Fnord ist die kleinste Zahl größer Null. Fnord ist der Grund, warum Ärzte wollen, dass du hustest. Fnord ist der unbenutzte Münzeinwurf am Spielautomaten. Fnord ist der Klang einer einzelnen klatschenden Hand. Fnord ist die Igno-Sekunde, bevor du die Lösch-Taste im falschen Dokument drückst.
So, ein bisschen Zeit für Anrufe. Haben wir hier auch noch im Chaos Radio. Heute etwas anders als sonst, nämlich ohne Chaos Computer Club. Und vielleicht sollte ich an dieser Stelle schon mal sagen, dass es im Dezember kein Chaos Radio geben wird, denn da findet der große Chaos Kongress in Hamburg statt. Vom 27. bis zum 29.
Dezember in Hamburg, genau, wo ja endlich alles über die Wahrheit erfahren wird. Nähere Informationen findet ihr entweder in www.ccc.de oder ihr kommt einfach vorbei. Das Ganze fängt an am 27. Dezember, so morgens um 9.10 Uhr, im Eidl steht der Bürgerhaus, in der alten Elbkornstraße 12, das ist hinterm Eidl steht der Platz, der sich in Hamburg durchfragt, findet das. Sonst kann auch Infos anfordern, von der 5. Rückporto an, CTC Schwenkestraße 85 in 202.55 Hamburg.
Ist schon interessant, was die Legion des Dynamischen, das Chaos-Dorges, weiß.
Ach ja, richtig. Die wird da natürlich auch vertreten sein. Vielleicht sogar was über die Frösche erzählen, aber das müssen wir erst mal intern, von T-Shirts verkaufen.
So, wir gucken hier weiter telefonieren. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo? Ja, wer bist denn du?
Der Bischof.
Mischof? Ich bin in meine National-Fairways-Armee für zwei Jahre in Singapur, als Vollzeitmodellin, und dann habe ich mich entschieden, einfach, weil ich mein Leben benötigen wollte.
Das war wieder ein Papst, ja. Ja, wer bist du denn?
Sehr schön.
Wie ist dein Vorname?
Das ist doch mal schön, dass man sich nochmal kennenlernt.
Dass das Gutes für dich treffen. Ist es richtig, dass du 1778 in die Loge der Illuminaten eingetreten bist?
Ja, ich wollte was erzählen.
Dann erzähl einfach alles, was du möchtest.
So es Zeit gibt, habe ich vor etwa 200 Jahren ein Buch geschrieben über einen Mann, der seine Seele an den Torse verkauft hat.
Und was ich erzählen wollte ist, dass er verstehen kann, was er getan hat.
So es Zeit gibt, hat er in einer Zeit gelebt, wo er keine andere Wahl hat, oder er glaubte, keine andere Wahl zu haben. Was ich sagen will, ist, dass ich ihn vergeben kann. Und da ihr auf dem Kortbus zu hören seid, und er vielleicht auch in der Leitung ist, Hallo Christian, ich möchte dir sagen, dass ich dich vergeben will.
Ich liebe dich.
Danke.
Hallo?
Ich bin der Ecke.
Robert, hallo.
Hallo Robert.
Man findet auch in Religionen sehr witzige Sachen zum Thema 5.
Erzähl mal.
Ich hab gerade mal durch Zufall rausgefunden. Man findet zum Beispiel, dass die Tora, also die jüdische Bibel, aus fünf Teilen besteht. Man findet, dass im Islam es fünf heilige Pflichten gibt. Moment, man findet in großen Nachlagewerken irgendwie sehr witzige Sachen. Wenn man einfach mal nur so die Stichworte eingibt, zum Beispiel fünf oder so, findet man ganz witzige Sachen. Zum Beispiel? Also, die fünf Säulen des Islam, so sinnlos es eigentlich erscheinen mag, scheint sich in Religion sehr viel auf fünf zu beziehen. Also ich weiß nicht, mehr als auf alle anderen Zahlen. Also es gibt selten eigentlich mal so drei oder sieben oder irgendwelche anderen Zahlen.
Aber du kannst die fünf Zahlen jetzt nicht zufällig gerade aufzählen.
Naja, mal überlegen, hier steht das Aufsagen des Glaubensbekenntnisses, die Verrichtung der täglichen Gebete, das Fasten im Ramadan, einmal im Leben nach Megapilgern und das Zahlen der Almosesteuer.
Ja, verrechte ich.
Ich meine die 5, wir nehmen alle mal unsere linke Hand, nehmen sie langsam vor ihre Augen und zählen einfach mal, wie viele Finger wir haben. Dann wissen wir, wie so alles 5 Säulen hat.
Ja, aber was ist denn mit dem Christentum irgendwie? Es gibt 10 Gebote, 12 jünger.
12 ist ja 2 mal 3 mal 2.
Na vielleicht ist Christentum irgendwie weiterentwickelt, ist ja das jüngste. Ich habe die Sendung nicht so ganz mitverfolgt, nur die letzte Stunde. Andreas war ja das letzte Mal nicht bei, ob er diesmal zu der 23 gesagt hat mit den Dimensionen.
Nee, Andreas ist nicht hier, also der konnte es nicht sagen, aber Jay Random Hacker hat es gesagt.
Jaja, eine der Möglichkeiten ist die Anzahl der Dimension 23. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Mit der Dimension haben wir das erwähnt?
Oh, ich bin mir da auch nicht mehr ganz sicher. Also es gibt diese Gleichung, die besagt, dass das Universum entweder 10 oder...
11 oder 23.
Vielleicht waren es auch 26. Also ich würde da lieber nochmal genauer nachgucken. Das ist eine relativ interessante Story. Im Wesentlichen ist es so, dass unser Universum garantiert keine vier Dimensionen hat, sondern mehr.
War die Antwort auf diese Geschichte nicht eigentlich 42?
Nee, vielleicht war es irgendwie die Summe von alles.
Genau, genau. Welche Konstante war das denn verdammt?
Die 42 war das mit dem Planeten, der den Sinn des Universums ausgerechnet hat.
Na ja, es gab auch eine Physik mit 42. Da waren doch alle sehr erstaunt, dass es rauskam. War das die Hubble-Konstante?
Ja genau, es war die Hubble-Konstante.
Die wurde instrumentell auf 42 bestimmt.
Also eigentlich liegt sie bei 50.
Aber das ändert sich ja immer, das wird ja mal angepasst.
Ja, die letzte Messung war 42, da waren sie wohl alle ganz stolz drauf.
Schließlich haben sie wirklich monatelang ihre Rechner darüber bestellt.
Da haben sie es so hingedreht, dass es da hinten sein sollte.
Insofern war es wahrscheinlich so eine Self-fulfilling Prophecy, wie der Landeort der ersten Mondfähre, der auch genau da aufgeschlagen ist. Und wir werden es mal beschrieben.
Self-fulfilling Prophecy sind überhaupt noch so ein Thema, das wir eigentlich nochmal diskutieren sollten.
Naja, das kann ich ja dem Chaos Computer Club mal vorschlagen. Ich danke dir erstmal. Bis denn. Da war es wieder, sein bis denn, was völlig Sinn entleert in den Etter und in die Telefonhörer gejagt wird.
Bis denn.
Total blödsinn, bis denn. Das sind die Telefonleitungen. Das sind die Telefonleitungen, Zapf.
Hallo, ja, eigentlich bin ich auch bekannt als der Hackbot, eben gerade im Internet.
Ah, ist klar, wir lesen dich die ganze Zeit hier mit. Also ich oft nicht so, weil ich ja auch noch die Regler schieben muss, aber Zapf ist schwerstens am chatten.
Jo, aber immerhin bin ich immer noch der Meinung, dass man das Eris von imanisieren nicht sollte, also dass man es verhindern sollte.
Dass man verhindert, dass es überhaupt irgendjemand imanitisiert, oder dass es jemand Besonderes ist.
Die Posten sollte schon vorangetrieben werden, aber imanisiert sollte es vielleicht doch nicht werden.
Willst Du nicht das letzte aller Dinge erfahren?
Also der Trick dabei ist, dass natürlich alle das Eschaton imanisieren wollen, nicht nur einige wenige, darum geht es ja.
Nee, aber jeder will es ja erfahren, irgendwann, früher oder später, oder?
Ja, richtig, und uns geht es darum, dass halt jeder das erfährt, nicht nur Ausgewirrte.
Naja, aber zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt sind wir immer ausgewählt, und sehen das Eschaton vor uns, wie wir es selbst imanisieren, irgendwie, doch.
Hast Du es denn schon mal imanisiert?
Wenn da noch nicht, ja ich meine, dann sehen wir es nicht mehr.
Und was ist mit den Fröschen?
Naja, also vor den Fröschen kommen eigentlich die Parkour.
Aber ich habe da noch eine andere Frage an Johnny, jetzt direkt, Entschuldige bitte, aber ich habe vor ungefähr anderthalb Jahren, ungefähr mal an Dich mir einige E-Mails geschickt und so, und Du hast es mir auch immer geantwortet, und damals hatte ich Dich nämlich gefragt, warum Du bei Snarku, bei diesem Webprovider, und dich gefragt hast, ob Du es kennst, und Du meintest, Mensch, ich bin ja die Illuminatenin, ich hätte das nächste Mal lesen, hast Du Dir jetzt vor dieser Sendung die drei Bände durchgelesen, oder?
Das ist eine ganz klare Antwort zu Nein.
Ich habe das während der Sendung getan.
Ich habe es immer noch nicht gelesen.
Jonny bereitet sich immer sehr gründlich vor, aber das haben wir Ihnen doch nicht aufgeben können.
Ich habe vorher gefragt, ob es nötig ist, dass ich es gelesen habe, und man sagte mir, ich bin ja hier eher der Busfahrer.
Ich fange jetzt mal kurz an zu parken, vielleicht ein bisschen Musik.
Und danach eminentisieren wir das Eschaton?
Nein. Wir sind ja von der anderen Seite. Das passt mir jetzt überhaupt nicht in den Terminkalender.
Das Eschaton wird auf jeden Fall gegen Ende dieses Jahres eminentisiert werden, wenn wir kurz vor dem Schritt in die Chaos-Zeit stehen.
Also wenn sich plötzlich ein blendendes Licht von außen durch das Fenster zwängt, dann lohnt es sich vielleicht hin zu gucken.
Ich sag's dir mal noch auf Arabisch gleich, wie zu diesem Disc Jockey. Mach mal Lala.
Gerillia Ontologie, die Grundtechnik all unserer Sendungen. Ontologie ist die Untersuchung des Seins der Dinge. Die Gerillia Methode besteht darin, die Bestandteile einer jeden Sendung so zu mischen, dass der Hörer auf jeder Seite entscheiden muß, wie viel davon ist Wahrheit und wie viel ist erfunden. Diese Form kreativen Schaffens scheint uns heutzutage aufgrund der beschleunigten Beschleunigung innerhalb neuen Wissens, neuer Theodorien, neuer Erfindungen und neuer Möglichkeiten gerechtfertigt, denn jede von uns entworfene Realitätslandkarte ist möglicherweise zur Zeit der Sendung bereits veraltet.
In diesem Sinne, Chaos Radio zum letzten Mal im Jahr 1997. Im Dezember gibt es keine Ausgabe. Im Januar allerdings gibt es eine neue Ausgabe vom Chaos Radio. Dann wieder mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute zu Gast die Legion des dynamischen Discords. Ich erinnere euch nochmal an den Chaos Kongress in Hamburg. Der findet statt vom 27. bis 29.
Dezember.
Ich erinnere an die Webadresse für diese Sendung. Die lautet www.ccc.de slash Chaos Radio. Mit großem C am Anfang. Und ich erinnere an die E-Mail Adresse, unter der ihr uns alle hier erreichen könnt.
Also zumindest die Legion.
Wahrscheinlich jetzt schwer, aber zumindest den Chaos Computer Club und mich. Und diese E-Mail Adresse lautet chaos.orb.de Und unter chaosradio.ccc.de im www. findet ihr auch Zugang zum Ticker, das heißt es gibt Rundmails vom Chaos Computer Club, die dann alle, die dort eingetragen sind, in dieser Liste automatisch per E-Mail zugeschickt bekommen. Und dort gibt es zum heutigen Thema der Sendung einige super interessante Links, also tragt euch da ein beim Ticker vom Chaos Radio. Die Adresse ist chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Johnny, das war's für heute. Gleich gibt's den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Und ähm, wollte ich noch was sagen? Tschüss und danke hier an die Legion, ne?
Heil Iris.
Herzlich Willkommen, bis morgens um vier haben wir gemeinsam das Vergnügen, Musik wäre jetzt ja groovig, denke ich mal. Bei den Temperaturen muss man sich auch ordentlich einschwingen, damit man nicht einfriert in der Nacht. Lehn euch zurück, genießt es noch ein bisschen wach zu bleiben. Ihr könnt ja auch nicht schlafen. Oder dürft nicht, weil ihr arbeiten müsst. Ich hoffe, die Musik ist ein guter Begleiter durch die Nacht. In diesem Sinne, die sind Omnivore. Ein Remix von The Beloved is, der aber lange lange nicht so schön ist, wie diese Originalversion hier von Kerel, das erste Stück. Und die haben sich eben schon angekündigt. Von Love Team aus ihrem aktuellen Album. An den Reglern saß Dr. Octagon in diesem Falle als The Automator.
Das ist ein Stück aus einer von drei aktuellen 12 inch Remix Maxis, die ist zur Zeit von Pizzicato 5 im Zuge ihres aktuellen Albums in, sag ich mal, gut sortierten Plattenleben zu kaufen gibt es. Und auch dies isn Remix, angefertigt für Edwin Collins, is ja zur Zeit so üblich, wenn aktuelles Album drausn is, gibts gleichzeitig auch Remix-Varianten davoten. Double 12-inch, I hear a new world, so heißt die Platte. Und hier von Deadly Avenger, I'm back. Wobei in diesem Falle mehr zu hören sein Duettpartner, der gute Mark E. Das war der Deadly Avenger Super Shine Mix von 70s Nights.